>>'MORRY
THESSTARTINGUS
T NOW.
>>, SPECIAL
EN F TAMPADIVISION.'RAWARE, T AA
D LOCAL LAENFOENENSEARTHE N RV
LAUNDRIE, A PERSONINTEREST
NVESTIGATORS BBY PIT
NOTEBOOK BELONGING TERSONAL S SK
ES FOUND I
UNDER WATEROUIDCEE TEAM I
SCENE USINL AVAILABLE  RESOURCEM
SCENR SEVERAL OW YOUE LL
DEDICATION AND PROFESSIONALIFOU
OUR
PARTNERSM E D
LOCA
COMPLEX INVESTIGATNS SUCD BY
ONE AGCY ALONE BUT THEREOOENCIE
ALL HERE
RTF THE ENVIRONMENCREEK PARK REE
LL TO THTIL FURTHER NOAN
INASK
PUBLIC TINTAIN DISTANCFROMANONN
HED TO PROTECT THE
DEE IS THE TOD'SS.
LENVESTIGATIVE AY  INQUIRIESHO.
LID CONTINK FOR YOURCES
N TO CLO.YOU.
>> WAS THEACKPACK FOUNAR
TI GABBY!
JUSTICE FOR GA
STHAT WAS FBIPE ENINUPDATE.ACK.
WHAT DOUE OF THAT.
YOU?
>> WELL, IT SOUND A
AND WE'LL LIKELY GETT NO IMPORT
EVENCE THAT ISHE AND WHAT
CONDITION IST ?
IS TSUICIDE?E ELEMENTS
ANY ICDEE
IS THERE ANYNDICATION OFR
IOOR ANYEV TO THE SCENE OF
E TR
>> ANDASEYOR THIAFS RIDOT
INVESTIGATION INTO THE MURDER, ?
>> THE MOSING
THAT I JUST LEARNEFRT
AND THAT REALLISES T THEK.
INDEED, THIS
LAUNDRIE AND DIED BY HA, DID H
EXPLANN?MAYBE EVEN REGRET.
SOMETHG IVONLY TO THLICE BUT TO
C BE S F THE,ER
WE TUBLIOU CERIN INDICATESPECIA,
HAHITHATT HAVEMEF OR
SU IDEATION HE WENT TO THE RESEN
BEENN TOUCH OR CORRESPONDING
MON MISSING, THEHE EXACTHAT O Y
>> VERY DIFFICUL AND A HAL CU
LET ME BRINGDI KAYE, OURCORRESP.
YOU  THE FBI
SPOKESMAN, THE FBI AGENTSPECAG
THWARI TNDER
WATER.
TELL US ABOU
BN CH SINCE
SEPTEMBEthN THE   PAM TO T
AREA.
Y CONDITNS T SDIVERS OUT HERNY Y
LOOKING FOR S SOME DEEEY
COULDN'T GET TE
WOULD HELP THEM OUT IN TARCH.
OWF THIS
PAULAR AREY UNDER
WATER BUT IT WAS
ACCESSIBLE.
YOARTHPROTESTERSHERE BEHINBUT I
ANOW FOR FAMIL
ST TODAY. DANATT  AASE,AS WE LYA
CONCLUSION.
>> WL, THERE'S ONE OTHER
IMPORTANT ISSUE HERE ANDT IS OFA
LAUNDRIE'S BODY, IF THAT'S WT  H
FAMILY OF IE HAD TNOT OPERATE W
PROTECT HIM OR WHATEVER, THAT'S
KINDNEHERE IS THE POSSIBILITY W
ADDITION